PROFESSOR 1: Yeah, any
questions about this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I actually have two.
One's an incidental question.
You keep mentioning
something that I never
heard of called "ardeeno",
or something like that.
PROFESSOR 1: Yes.
AUDIENCE: What is that?
PROFESSOR 1: Arduino is a tiny
little microcontroller-- not
related to video games, really.
But it's a tiny little
microcontroller.
And you connect it
up to a circuit,
and then it can tell an LED
to blink every five seconds.
And it can detect when
you press a button,
and it can read off
of a light sensor,
whether the lights are on.
So it's a little
kind of computer chip
that you program to do
one particular task that
connects out to the world.
AUDIENCE: So then
the more generally--
I'm curious what the connection
with Kinect is in this course.
If we didn't want to use
Kinect, is that an option?
The reason I'm a little nervous
is because I don't own one,
and I don't have access to one.
So if I end up building
something that requires Kinect,
then I won't be able to use it.
PROFESSOR 1: Yes.
So you can buy a Kinect that'll
work with a PC for about $200.
If you don't want to use
a Kinect, that's fine.
We have four Kinects
and computers with Unity
that is all set up to use it.
So if you want to use a
Kinect, you have the resources.
AUDIENCE: OK-- not a necessary
part of doing this course.
PROFESSOR 1: Not a
necessary part, no.
AUDIENCE: --to Unity and
focus on web apps or whatever.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You could do your
own thing, totally.
And the Kinect is--
really, it's amazingly simple.
So if you have a game
that connects with a mouse
click and a drag, then you
can instantly take the Kinect
and say, where it was
a mouse click and drag,
make it the palm.
And it takes like zero
transference, right?
PROFESSOR 2: Yeah.
So in those simulations
you saw, all
you need to do to change them
from being a Kinect thing
to a not Kinect
thing is uncheck one
of the scripts in this panel.
So pretend this were
my own product--
which isn't on this computer--
this would be with
Kinect, and then this
would be with the mouse.
So you don't have to
exclusively choose one.
AUDIENCE: I see.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah, and then
you can program a whole Kinect
thing on your
computer just assuming
mouse clicks are Kinect.
And then when you're
ready, drag on the script
or click on the
little thing, and it's
ready to work on
a Kinect system.
That's part of what he's been
tasked to do over the last six
months was make it really easy
to use Kinect if you want it.
Any other questions?
And if I don't see
your hand up, it's
probably because you're in
my periphery, so say things.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Thought of detecting,
[INAUDIBLE.] Is there anything
we should download,
development kit or anything,
to use at home so that
we're on the same page
as what's happening in class?
PROFESSOR 1: Good question.
PROFESSOR 2: There
is a Kinect SDK,
and you can download it
from the Microsoft website.
We are using the newer
version of the Kinect.
However, the older
version is very similar,
and I think you
just have to remove
the little v2 at the
end of all the Kinect
references in the code.
PROFESSOR 1: And it
only works on Windows.
PROFESSOR 2: It does only
work on Windows, yes.
PROFESSOR 1: And I see
a little apple, I think.
AUDIENCE: I have a thinking on
this, so I could probably work.
PROFESSOR 1: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR 2: Great.
AUDIENCE: What only
works on Windows?
PROFESSOR 1: The Kinect, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
That's [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 1: All right.
[THE PROFESSOR AND STUDENT
LAUGH]
Any other?
Nope?
All right, then--
AUDIENCE: Is there
a Kinect simulator
so that you could
run it on a Mac?
Or does that also
only work on Windows?
PROFESSOR 1: It
probably just only works
on Windows, because it uses
developments library, a DLL
link library that runs
on Windows and knows
what to do with the
inputs that it's getting.
PROFESSOR 2: The
version one, I think,
can do it-- you can do on Mac.
PROFESSOR 1: Oh.
PROFESSOR 2: It's specific
to the version two.
The version two, it
pushes the USB 3.0s back--
like, really hard.
And it's so much
data, that I don't
think Microsoft wanted to put
any extra effort into that.
It used to only
work on Windows 8.
PROFESSOR 1: And now we
can work on Windows 10.
PROFESSOR 2: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 1: Yay!
All right.
So thank you.
AUDIENCE: Would
it be useful to do
a poll of who uses Macs,
who uses Windows, and Linux,
and things like that?
PROFESSOR 2: I mean, you can
still program it on the Mac
and just do it with the mouse.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR 2: And then just check
the little box, as it were.
PROFESSOR 1: And yeah, so
you can send it over to one
of the systems that has the
Kinect and uncheck the box.
It shouldn't end
up being a problem.
If you start working
on a Mac, then it
should take a little bit
of time to look and go,
oh, yeah, no problem-- check
this, send it over here,
and it'll work.
What I would say is,
don't worry about it.
Do what's comfortable
right now, and then we'll
figure out what needs
to be adjusted later.